pokémon go le rêve de tout dresseur de
pokémon est enfin arrivé car nous
pouvons enfin capturer des pokémon dans
la vraie vie
pokémon go est un jeu téléchargeable sur
le store proposant une réalité augmentée
nous pouvons capturer des pokémon
partout dans le monde tout en se
promenant c'est déjà un buzz phénoménal
et le jeu pokémon est une réelle
réussite
moi même je suis à fond sur ce jeu et
j'essaie de vous en proposer en vidéo le
jeu est accessible à tous et permet à
pokémon d'avoir un nouveau souffle et
d'accueillir de nouvelles personnes
in intéressé par pokémon jusqu'à
maintenant cependant fan de pokémon
nouveau dresseur de nombreux mystères
sont présents ensuite à la sortie
récente de ce jeu et voici donc trois
théories que je vous propose
depuis la sortie de pokémon or et
pokémon argent des pokémon extrêmement
rares sont apparus sur la licence
pokémon et ce sont les pokémon chagny ou
chromatique en français ce sont des
créatures de couleur différente de
l'habituel le plus connu d'entre eux
serait le lait viator rouge
mais comment trouve-t-on un pokémon
shiny comme je l'aï dit récemment les
pokémon chagny sont des pokémon
extrêmement rare car il ya une chance
sur 8192 en trouver un à chaque
rencontre jusqu'à pokémon diamant et
perle où le poker radar est apparue
exprès pour trouver des pokémon shy'm et
chances d'en trouver seront ensuite
encore plus grande dans les prochains
jeux grâce au charme khroma qui permet
d'augmenter par trois les chances de
trouver un pokémon chagny cependant vous
devez capturer tous les pokémon du
pokédex nationale pour la voir il est
apparu à partir de pokemon noir de et
blanc 2 à partir des jeux xy les chances
d'en trouver un son de une sur 4096 soit
le double des anciennes versions en
possession du chant chrome à vos chances
arrive donc à une sur 1365 et pourquoi
je vous raconte tout ça et bien imaginez
si les pokémon szczesny tu es présent
dans pokémon go les fréquentes
apparitions ne sont déjà pas énorme
alors imaginez la chance de trouver un
pokémon shiny depuis xy on aurait donc
une chance sur 4096 d'en trouver un ce
serait vraiment très difficile
cependant énormément de joueurs de
pokémon sont ce qu'on appelle des
chasseurs c'est à dire qu'ils chassent
les pokémon chagny et chagny sont
présents depuis pokémon or et argent et
n'ont jamais été retiré depuis donc
pourquoi nous n'aurions pas de pokémon
shani dans le jeu comme dit le tweet de
nous titeuf c'est seulement trois lignes
de code en plus dans le flou c'est donc
rien de nombreuses rumeurs sont déjà
présentes comme quoi nous pourrions
posséder le léviathan rouge en faisant
évoluer un magic a prénommé en raid
malheureusement il s'agit d'un fake mais
cela montre bien l'engouement que les
joueurs ont pour les pokémon shiny
qu'ils aimeraient avoir dans le jeu et
si nous complétons le pokédex de pokémon
go est ce que le professeur nous
donnerait le charme khroma ce serait
vraiment très intéressant et donnerait
un second souffle au jeu sans compter le
marketing car les joueurs achèterait en
masse des leurres pour attirer des
pokémon et à augmenter leurs chances
voir des pokémon chromatique qu'en
pensez vous mais en moins cela
obligerait les gens à rester dehors
vraiment longtemps suite à la rareté de
ces bestioles et je pense que niang tic
souhaiterait ne pas avoir de drames sur
les bras suite à ceux ci mais je garde
espoir tout de même
mais où est un pokémon légendaires est
inscrit dans les codes du jeu cela a été
vérifié par des hackers il fait partie
des cent cinquante et un pokémon de la
première génération il faut donc
l'attraper pour pouvoir compléter le
pokédex personne n'a encore capturé miu
à l'heure d'aujourd'hui ni aucun
légendaire jeu comporte sulfures à
artico d'un électeur mewtwo et miou
cependant mieux est considéré comme un
pokémon mythique et non comme un
légendaire dans le jeu c'est une
référence au premier jeu pokémon car miu
est introuvable contrairement aux autres
pokémon légendaires d'ailleurs je fais
une aparté mais chaque pokémon trouver
sur pokémon go est disponible dans des
lieux précis nous pouvons trouver des
magnetti et voltaire dans des zones
industrielles ou proches des centrales
électriques ou encore des tentacules
magica autres pokémon de type auprès de
la mère ou autre point d'eau tout comme
dans le jeu de base
il y a donc une logique et bien si on
s'intéresse un peu plus au premier jeu
pokémon une théorie s'offre à nous car
en effet dans les anciennes versions on
peut aller dans un manoir pokémon à
cramoisy et découvrir un fameux journal
d'un aventurier chercheurs de pokémon on
peut donc lire dans ce journal que mios
a été découvert par cet aventurier en
guyane en amérique du sud
qu'est ce que cela veut dire je rappelle
que muse est considéré comme un pokémon
mythique et non comme un pokémon
légendaires donc il se pourrait qu'il
soit déjà disponible quelque part dans
le monde sans être lié par un événement
comme tout le monde pourrait s'y
attendre il faudrait donc traversé
l'atlantique pour aller capturer le
célèbre new mais rien ne nous est dit
sur le fait qu'il soit capturables ou
non il se peut qu'on puisse le combattre
mais non le capturer en tout cas cette
théorie est plausible et ce serait
vraiment une référence au premier jeu
pokémon
je ne sais pas ce que vous en pensez
mais ce serait vraiment incroyable que
miu soit disponible seulement là bas
cependant tout le monde ne pourrait pas
complété son pokédex et je me vois mal
payé un billet d'avion juste pour un
mieux en 50 pixels personnellement je ne
pense pas qu une antique ferait ceci
mais cette théorie reste bonne
151 pokémon sont disponibles dans le jeu
dont les fameux sulfures à artico d'un
électeur et mios tout ils sont présents
dans le jeu mais ils sont néanmoins
introuvable et possède 0% de capture on
ne peut donc pas les attraper est ce que
ces pokémon ne sont alors pas encore
disponible je le pense mais pourquoi ni
en tic va certainement gardé ses pokémon
pour allonger le jeu et le faire durer
c'est pourquoi ils sortiront ces pokémon
introuvable plus tard d'ailleurs il est
fort probable qu'un jour les autres
génération de pokémon soit ajoutée pour
continuer le jeu et rallonger sa durée
de vie on suppose alors que ces pokémon
apparaîtront suite à des événements
créés par niang tic
c'est ce que je pense aussi dans les
anciennes versions comme diamant et
perle par exemple des événements été
créés dans des lieux précis comme le
japon évidemment afin d'obtenir d'arc
rails ar c'est luce ou encore schelin
par exemple cela donnait une plus longue
vie au jeu et donc le marché se portait
bien
je pense sincèrement que niang tic
ferait la même chose avec ces pokémon
cependant les teams bleu rouge et jaune
sont certainement pas là par hasard ces
équipes en fonction de ce que vous avez
choisi de rejoindre désignerait quel
oiseau légendaire vous rencontreriez la
team bleus pourraient alors posséder
artico d'un la rouge se fera et la jaune
elector malheureusement on ne pourrait
donc pas complété son pokédex
entièrement c'est pourquoi n'y antic a
parlé de la possibilité de faire des
échanges dans les prochaines mises à
jour
on pourrait alors s'échanger les oiseaux
légendaire pour que tout le monde puisse
les voir dans le pokédex mais qu'en
est-il de 1000 to you to est un petit
peu à part des autres légendaire car il
est le légendaire des premières versions
je pense que mewtwo posséderait alors un
événement apparaît en fonction de la
masse torball car oui la master ball est
codée dans le jeu mais n'est pas encore
disponible mewtwo est très célèbre pour
sa difficulté à être capturé c'est
pourquoi la master ball seraient
disponibles je verrai bien le professeur
vous donner la master gaulle et vous
demander d'aller chercher min où il
serait dans un lieu précis et un
mouvement de foule serait créée pour
l'avoir vu l'ampleur du pokémon et je me
demande si niang 6e les frais achetés
mewtwo par un quelconque endroit
marketing ou lieux touristiques
tout ceci 1 reste un mystère
bien évidemment tout ceci ne sont que
des théories en majeure partie créée et
écrite par moi même et notre imagination
peut être infinie sur les nouveautés de
ce jeu cependant tout ça reste plausible
il est fort probable que plusieurs de
ces théories se réalise un jour et je
l'espère n'oubliez pas de faire
attention au tour de vous lorsque vous
jouez à pokémon go un homme averti en
vaut deux cette application est vraiment
génial et révolutionnaire et j'espère
qu'elle réunira tous les fans de pokémon
encore longtemps
c'était argot rock que le line up soit
avec vous vive pokémon et notre enfance
oui
oh